[Music]
thank you
this is a video of me falling in love
it's only nine seconds long which is why
we are having to Loop it again and again
I didn't know that much about it
compared to everything I know now I
barely even knew how to look at it
properly but I knew that it was
beautiful and that I wanted to see more
[Music]
that is James who many of you know as
our master of microscopes he is the
scientist and I would also say the
artist behind just about everything
we've been able to see in our Collective
Journey Through the micro Cosmos now
some of you may know the story of how
that Journey got started how I Hank
Green saw James's work online and then
reached out to see if he would want to
start this channel together when I saw
the videos he posted the thing that got
me most excited was that I didn't know
like I feel like most people have some
vague sense the tardigrades are cool and
that single-celled organisms exist but
when I was watching James's videos I
never knew what I was looking at I
didn't have any categories to place
these things into I felt like I was
watching unnarrated footage from a
nature documentary of another planet and
that is a feeling that I liked quite a
lot luckily J James decided to let us
join in on his journey sharing his
videos and knowledge so that we could
pull more people into the microcosmos
but James's Journey was already well
underway before we found his content and
today we want to learn more about that
path because here on Journey to the
microcosmos we've had the chance to
explore the history of microscopy
through the lives of former Masters but
microscopy isn't some ancient field
contained only in Dusty books it is
still evolving through the work of
students and scientists and hobbyists
who are finding New Paths through
microscopy today
for James love began where maybe you'd
least expect it
[Music]
I was taking a lab course on wastewater
treatment yes I know it sounds
disgusting and it was we had jars full
of human ways and then we had to look at
those samples under the microscope to
see what creatures were growing in there
and I thought it was going to be boring
but then I put a drop of that slimy
stuff on the slide place the cover slip
on top and looked at it under the
microscope and it was like love at first
sight I couldn't believe what I was
seeing I remember seeing something that
looked like a worm with a chainsaw mouth
which took me completely by surprise I
had no idea what I was looking at but
later I learned that it was a rotifer I
went into the course knowing absolutely
nothing about microbes but I came out of
it knowing that a few hours of
microscopina class weren't enough for me
I had to get my own microscope even
though it was a big expense for a poor
student and while I waited for it to
arrive I spent hours and hours studying
everything I could find about microbes
many of the organisms that we get to
watch with James come from the Polish
Palms close to where he lives but the
first sample he ever studied under his
own microscope came from a puddle close
to his home and the video of paratrix
ciliates that we opened the video with
that is the first thing he recorded on
it
I have so much from that first week of
microscopy to look back on I had learned
enough about peritric ciliates in my
coursework to identify them in my first
life but other creatures were harder for
me like this little green guy I spent
all night looking at pictures of algae
only to accidentally stumble on an
organism I'd never heard of before
called The Desmond and after hours of
Googling I realized that this was a
Desmet it's funny remembering how much
time it took me to realize I was looking
at a Desmond because they are super
common
finding one and identifying it is like
identifying a cow in a field full of
cows but I found really unusual things
in that first week of microscopy like
these giant purple amoeba that I haven't
been able to find again since and there
were odd things like these techamiba
that I didn't even think there were
microbes at first it was also confusing
to understand but it became easier and
easier the more I learned
these early videos you know they might
not be James's finest work he's holding
a camera close to the eyepiece with his
hand so sometimes things are a little
shaky or blurry so for those of us who
have gotten used to the clarity of his
footage this is a different experience
but that's what makes these older videos
for me so fascinating the work James
produces now is so incredible to look at
that it's easy to take the work going
into them for granted to assume that the
microcosmos simply looks like that all
of the time the fascinating organisms he
finds the Vivid tableaus they paint
across our screen those belong to the
microcosmos but they are revealed to us
through skills that James has been
honing for hours and hours every day
since he studied these first early
slides those are ours that build up into
years of finding the right places to
sample of devising new strategies to
house those samples and keep the
organisms inside them alive and then
ours spent fine-tuning his skills on the
microscope understanding what techniques
to use to bring different layers of the
micro Cosmos to life
I think microscopy provides me with
creative ideas everything becomes a
question of can I use this in microscopy
for example I heard once that hydras are
often found in aquariums
so I went to some pet stores bought some
aquatic plants and set up my first micro
tank the aquatic plants came with some
snails one day when I was looking at a
snail under the microscope I found this
green Hydra stretching off of the snail
shell and that's the beauty of the
microcosmos you can find the things
you're looking for in places you never
expect to find them and later I created
a YouTube channel to share some of my
videos with my professor and I realized
that I love recording videos of microbes
I'm kind of like a hoarder of microscopy
footage
James isn't kidding about that he
estimates that he has more than 5 000
hours of footage now you could watch all
10 Fast and Furious movies
269 times in 5 000 hours and despite Vin
Diesel's best intentions it would
probably not produce nearly as much
drama and heartbreak as what James has
recorded
the more I learned the more excited I
got about microbes I contacted
scientists to start volunteering in Labs
I share some videos on YouTube I posted
what I found on Reddit and then one day
one of my videos went viral and that's
how Hank found me
and sharing his work helped James find
one of his most important collaborators
and mentors Dr Hanover Esteban a
professor in microbiology at Bournemouth
University who has been studying
ciliates for decades
ciliates are single-celled eukaryotes
known for the hair cilia that cover
their bodies and James has become
particularly interested in them ciliates
are a very very diverse group of
organisms including everything from this
nactoloclamus to our favorite
trumpet-like stentors and it turns out
that thanks to his persisted sampling
James had a real knack for finding very
rare ciliates
in one of my favorite places I found
this weird ciliate I didn't know that
Professor Esteban was following my work
but she messaged me to ask me about the
super rare micropy was Finding even
though she has been in this field for so
long she had never seen a species like
this so we start texting about microbes
and over time we talked more and more
about the rare microbes and the
interesting ciliates we are finding and
now we even publish papers together when
I found the extremely rare legendary
loyeza she was the first person I called
I remember pacing around in circles in
my living room telling her all about the
tentacles extending
there are always all sorts of lessons
you can take from a story like James's
his persistence is love for the craft
the joy of microscopy but there's
something else too community
so much of James's story is about being
alone hours spent hunched over a
microscope but so much of it is about
not being alone about finding people who
share his love for the microcosmos and
even people who don't know yet that they
share that love
there are people he talks to every day
about microbes like Professor estepon
there are people he regales in meetings
with funny stories about the Absurd
lengths he's gone to for his microbes
like those of us on the journey to the
micro Cosmos team and there are even
people he doesn't know like many of you
with every video we get to see through
his eyes a little bit and journey to
another world individuals brought
together by a beam of light wielded by a
master's hands
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
if you are interested in beginning your
own microscopy Journey you can head on
over to microcosmos.store where we've
got all the stuff that you need to get
started including microscopes slides and
even a micro bumper sticker that says
tardigrade Enthusiast so you can let
everyone around you know that if they're
out there searching for a person who
shares their love of the micro Cosmos
you are that person
foreign
speaking of people who shared that love
these on the screen right now are the
names of our patreon patrons these are
the folks who have made it possible for
us to go on this wonderful Journey that
I have been so happy to have been
included on so thank you to all of them
for being such a huge part of what we do
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]